beaucoup en direct ce jeudi pour parler
de la présidentielle est bien évidemment
de la noce des variations ces manuels
battront je suis avec guillaume rottée
directeur de l'info figaro magazine pour
jeunes en 30 ans on pourra essayer de
répondre à toutes vos questions de vie
n'hésitez pas à en poser aussi être
mieux possible on va vous écris ces
cases vides et même un tour du portalet
la première question un peu gêné
parce que
parce qu'un prix négociable
comme si c'était une forme d'obligation
que d'un engagement personnel fort du
président de la république on va dire
qu'on est sur du classique c'est une
lettre qui n'est pas très longue la
vocation à être reproduite dans la
presse quotidienne régionale demain
c'est une lettre qui est assez classique
dans sa forme emmanuel macron dit j'ai
fait tout ce que j'ai pu depuis cinq ans
mais j'ai pas fini il ya encore des
défis il le dresse les skis ce ce qui
pourrait ressembler à la lam horse d'un
programme et on est très général un
petit peu sur l'économie un petit peu
sur l'école un petit peu sur la sécurité
et puis il dit ayez confiance en moi
évidemment je prépare une campagne
normale mais c'est pas si grave donc
encore une fois on sent que emmanuel
macron devait se plier à cette formalité
mais qu' il n'y a pas la solennité ni la
surprise qui a pu avoir dans le passé
dans d'autres annonces du président
sortant oui parce qu'il faut rappeler
qui sait c'est quelque chose qu'il
attendait de faire depuis un moment
cette séance il a peut-être un peu jouer
la montre il a été pris de court par ce
qui s'est passé en ukraine oui disons
que c'est effectivement là non surprise
par excellence cette cette
déclaration de candidature chacun savait
emmanuel macron d'ailleurs l'avait déjà
laissé entendre très clairement depuis
plusieurs mois qu'il serait candidat
il a attendu le dernier moment peut-être
à cause de la crise ukrainienne mais je
pense que de toute façon c'était son
intérêt encore une fois
l'objectif du président de la république
c'est qu'il n'y ait pas de campagne
c'est à dire que y est les candidats qui
se bagarre entre eux qui font des
meetings et pendant ce temps-là
impression de la république qui
surplombe qui est aux affaires aux
affaires du coc vie de jusqu'à ces
derniers jours et maintenant aux
affaires delà de la crise du crédit yen
mais comme s'il fallait enjamber 7 cette
campagne présidentielle en attendant les
commentaires qui me dit le suspense
était insoutenable
effectivement tout le monde s'attendait
cette à cette annonce et il fallait
qu'elle arrive puisque il fallait se
déclarer avant demain oui c'est vrai
même s'il y avait débat entre les
spécialistes pour savoir s'il devait y
avoir une formalisation de cette de
cette candidature il fallait évidemment
ça c'est la règle juridique que le
président de la république
sois candidat auprès du conseil
constitutionnel
mais après tout ils auraient pu pour un
son téléphone et annoncer ça à laurent
fabius le président du conseil ou en
tout cas il y aurait une petite lettre
de toute façon ils avaient largement ses
parrainages donc il était vraiment libre
dot dans le choix de l'annonce le fait
par exemple de ne pas se déclarer à 20h
en direct dans une grande chaîne le fait
de faire ça le lendemain d'une
déclaration qui elle était importante et
qui est d'ailleurs une très forte
audience sur la crise en ukraine ça
montre que pour emmanuel macron il faut
passer par cette campagne par cette
candidature mais c'est comme si c'était
une formalité en fait tellement sa part
et à ses yeux naturel l'objectif étant
évidemment que pour les français aussi
ça apparaisse naturelle selon lui de le
réélire en allant certes heures dans les
commentaires qui nous dit donc il
essaiera dans ces circonstances d'éviter
les débats grâce à une grâce à ce type
de candidature et ben en fait c'est
qu'ils répondent ils répondent assez
précisément à ça il dit
cette élection se termine cette élection
compte tenu de ce qui se passe je ne
pourrais pas mené campagne comme je leur
ai souhaité en raison du contexte mais
avec clarté engagement j'expliquerai
notre projet donc déjà il dit bah oui si
vous vous attendez à un très grand
nombre de débats et ben non vous pourrez
pas les vous ne pourrez pas les avoir
mais ça non plus ce n'est pas une
surprise puisque son entourage avait
déjà laissé entendre qu'il ne voulait
pas débattre avec les autres candidats
en tout cas avant le second tour
effectivement justement sur ce sur le
projet ne présente aucun programme
finalement dans cette dans cette lettre
il est même encore très flou alors il
est très flou ce qui est intéressant
quand même c'est que c'est que il trace
des pistes alors il commence par
l'économie ça c'est vraiment la
signature d'emmanuel macro emmanuel
macron c'est l'homme qui promettait de
remettre la france en mouvement et de
toute évidence est toujours son objectif
alors il dit il faudra travailler plus
ça ne vous rappelle quelque chose ça
peut-être petit clin d'oeil à nicolas
sarkozy dont il ne désespère pas
d'obtenir le ralliement et poursuivre la
baisse des impôts sur le travail et la
production donc là vraiment c'est clair
c'est économique d'abord et puis ensuite
il ya les skis sde annonce qui pourrait
être forte sur l'école il dit la
priorité sera donnée à l'école et à nous
enseignants qui seront plus vivre pour
respecter au mieux
forte autour de l'école pour donner plus
d'autonomie aux responsables
d'établissements scolaires et pour
permettre une gestion plus individualisé
de la carrière des profs en gros pour
promouvoir les meilleurs et pas faire
avancer tout le monde au même rythme à
l'ancienneté il a aussi visé il vise
aussi certains candidats dans cette
lettre nous ne nous trompons pas nous ne
répondra pas à ces défis en réalisant le
repli ou en cultivant la nostalgie
l'enjeu est de bâtir la france de nos
enfants pas de ressasser la france de
notre enfance on voit qu'ils visent
clairement avec ses formules oui c'est
clairement d'abord eric zemmour a
ensuite peut-être eric zemmour c'est
pour le côté nostalgique et le côté ne
nous enfermons pas c'est évidemment
contre contre marine le pen c'est le
seul passage politiciens de ceux de
cette déclaration de candidature il dit
il ya des bouleversements et on ne peut
pas ce qu'on peut pas se replier sur soi
on ne peut pas être nostalgique et il
dit l'enjeu est de bâtir la france de
nos enfants pas de ressasser la france
de notre enfance et un peu plus loin il
dit je suis candidat pour continuer de
préparer l'avenir de nos enfants et même
de nos petits enfants c'est à se
demander s'il va pas changer la
constitution pour pouvoir se représenter
une troisième fois mais en tout cas ce
qui est sûr c'est que effectivement là
aussi on est dans un maquereau classique
j'allais presque dire attendu d'abord
l'homme qui veut réformer
en premier l'économie et deuxièmement
l'homme qui refuse de s'enfermer dans
une forme de nostalgie c'est le côté
macro moderne même si il ya un petit
passage après sur la france mais je
dirais qu'il est suffisamment il dit
qu'il faut qu'ils l'aiment la france ce
qui est une bonne chose mais il n'y a
pas de n'est pas vraiment de
d'engagement précis de ce côté là il ya
quand même il dit nous avons une
certaine manière d'être au monde chaque
canton chaque ville chaque village
ça c'est nous avons une histoire une
langue une culture ça je pense que c'est
la réponse à ceux qui pourraient trouver
que c'est un homme qui est trop ouvert à
la modernité donc il est contre la
nostalgie de zemmour mais quand même il
est très attaché à la france et à ses à
ses campagnes à ces villages 20 c'est
peut-être une c'est peut-être ça qu'on
appelle le en même temps effectivement
et est ce qu'on peut penser que c'est
une
et c'est une réponse à cause de
critiques des gis les jeunes sur cette
ses traces et des dates trop centralisée
qu'il peut représenter alors il n'y a
pas de réponse directe au gilet jaune
mais effectivement il ya cette idée que
il faille
qu'il faille tenir compte des
territoires mais quand même quand il
rend hommage aux villes au village c'est
d'abord pour l'art de vivre enraciné et
encore une fois c'est l'histoire c'est
la langue c'est la culture il n'y a pas
de d'éléments concrets d'engagement
envers une moindre centralisation en
revanche si vous parlez des gilet jaune
j'ai cherché dans ce texte il y avait
une forme d'autocritique c'est à dire
s'il reconnaissait qu'il avait pu
échouer et alors là aussi c'est du
maquereau 100% pur jus parce que c'est
pas forcément le l'humilité qui
l'étouffent où les houles et où les où
les regrets il dit nous n'avons pas tout
réussi il est des choix qu'avec
l'expérience acquise auprès de vous je
ferai sans doute différemment mais les
transformations engagées ont permis de
vivre mieux donc comme chantait edith
piaf il ne regrette rien et services et
demi mais à coups de feu entre
guillemets qui l'avait déjà fait c'est
pas c'est pas une nouveauté de
l'entendre dire quelque chose comme ça
non c'est vrai mais on peut dire que il
ne leur dit pas beaucoup pourquoi parce
que il voit bien comment dans cette
crise dans cette succession de crises
crise sanitaire puis crise
internationale avec l'ukraine les
français font font assez largement bloc
autour de lui jamais il n'a été aussi
populaire jamais les intentions de vote
ne lui ont été aussi favorable et donc
il n'y a aucune raison de
effectivement on avait une question
aussi sur la sur la façon d'annoncer
cette candidature la cesse et diffusé
dans tous les médias mais surtout sa
façon à lui de le faire c'est de le
mettre dans l'est dans les journaux de
presse régionale pourquoi avoir fait ce
choix alors je pense que c'est
effectivement aussi un petit clin d'oeil
aux territoires emmanuel macron est un
homme qui n'avait jamais été élu avant
d'accéder à la présidence de la
république et donc c'est pour montrer
que il s'intéresse aussi au pays dans
toute sa diversité maintenant pour être
honnête je trouve que ça relève plus du
gadget qu'autre chose parce que cette
lettre il a envoyé à tous les journaux
mais sachant que les diffuser à à 20h15
eh bien elle est aujourd'hui sur tous
les sites d'information à commencer par
celui du figaro donc le côté je parle
d'abord aux territoires me semble-t-il
c'était plus un processus de
communication qu'une réalité
effectivement c'est plus de la
communication est ce qu'on peut se
rappeler d'autres dans sa façon de faire
est ce qu'il ya des précédents
d'annoncer sa candidature comme ça dans
une lettre alors non il n'y a pas de
précédent pour les présidents sortants
il y a eu des précédents avec jacques
chirac il y avait effectivement déclaré
sa candidature dans la dans la presse
nationale c'était à la voix du nord me
semble-t-il mais les les présidents
sortants avaient choisi au bien de faire
une déclaration à la télévision ça
pouvait être au 20 heures de tf1 pour
nicolas sarkozy ça pouvait être une
déclaration solennelle depuis l'elysée
pour charles de gaulle il y avait eu une
originalité c'est jacques chirac qui par
surprise à l'occasion d'un voyage à
avignon était dans une conférence de
presse commune avec la maire d'avignon
qui est qui étaient du même parti et à
qui il dit à bas puisque vous me posez
la question comme je vais vous dire oui
je suis candidat mais une annonce comme
ça par lettre d'un président sortant
sauf erreur de ma part ça ne s'était
jamais on attendait justement peut-être
une annonce de candidature pendant là le
salon de l'agriculture par exemple où il
devait faire un long une longue
déambulation mais finalement une fois de
plus la crise du crédit la rattraper
quelque part oui et je pense que tout ça
est très bien gérée et très bien
maîtrisée
aujourd'hui ce qui intéresse les
français c'est pas de savoir si emmanuel
macron et candidats ils le savent depuis
des mois
et donc
de réserver la l'intervention
une forme de hiérarchie et c'est
hiérarchie dans l'importance des sujets
d'abord la croix
et préoccupations des français donc là
je pense qu'il a raison maintenant est
ce qu est ce qui peut ce qu'est ce qui
va se passer il est officiellement
candidat mais le sera-t-il vraiment
puisqu'il est toujours président il va
le rester quand même et il ya une grande
crise qui est en cours oui d'ailleurs il
a déjà annoncé que il annulait le
premier de ces de ses meetings qui
étaient prévus à marseille et compte
tenu de la situation je pense qu'il va
faire en sorte de d'être le plus
président possible et le moins candidat
possible et je pense que il aura raison
puisque encore une fois l'actualité
l'ukrainienne écrase tout après est ce
qu'il va faire des ddd
pas parce qu'il ne veut pas débattre
avec la totalité des autres candidats ce
qui le remettrait au même niveau que
qu'une nathalie arthaud qu'un couteau
puisqu'on sait depuis quelques minutes
qu'il a ses 500 signatures pas pour ça
que
pendant la campagne effectivement
on peut vous parler des grands meetings
ces grands meetings le premier devait
avoir lieu à marseille est ce qu'un
candidat à sa réélection frau fait des
gros meeting alors oui
oui et on se souvient en particulier de
nicolas sarkozy qui est le dernier
président en date
fin 2016 françois hollande avait annoncé
qu'ils n'étaient pas
représenter francophonie sont des
tableaux dans le dans le pays mais en
2012 nicolas sarkozy avait fait des
meetings il en a d'ailleurs fait un peu
trop ça lui avait coûté cher et c'était
la fameuse affaire de ce2 ce2 ce
dépassement de budget parce qu'il avait
besoin de mobiliser les français est
d'ailleurs ses meetings lui avait permis
de rattraper une partie de son retard
sur françois hollande ce n'est pas la
même chose avec emmanuel macron qui
encore une fois est archi favori donc il
peut le faire mais à mon avis il en fera
peu dans la mesure où ça donnerait le
sentiment aux français qu'ils se disent
très en quelque sorte de la priorité qui
est celle de la gestion de la crise dont
je parierais plutôt pour un nombre de
meetings limité mais je vous dis pas ce
que je parie parce que j'ai pas de
certitude maintenant que tous les
candidats se sont déclarés est-ce que la
campagne va vraiment débuter c'est est
ce qu'on dit depuis quelques mois c'est
trop payé le pen a débuté est ce que
sarko est le cas alors
je pense que avec les éléments que
manuel macron donne dans sa lettre aux
français il n'y a pas de quoi bâtir un
véritable débat puisque encore une fois
il n'ya pas là un programme développé
mais simplement quelques grands
principes de réforme et qui d'ailleurs
pour la plupart sont des réformes qu'il
a déjà engagé il n'ya rien par exemple
sur des sujets aussi concrets aussi
difficile que la réforme des retraites
donc pour l'instant
emmanuel macron continue à surplomber le
débat politique on peut pas dire qu'il
soit vraiment entré en campagne avec
cette déclaration moi je prends le pari
que il ne voudra pas le faire de façon
de façon classique parce que ce n'est
pas son intérêt est évidemment face à ça
il ya les autres candidats qu'ils nous
disent mais maintenant entrer dans
l'arène vous avez vu que valérie
pécresse a réagi immédiatement après la
publication de cette lettre vous avez vu
que eric zemmour par vidéo interposée
dit au prochain débat public il est
temps de débattre ils vont tous essayé
de le faire rentrer dans le jeu de la
campagne et lui probablement fera tout
son possible pour ne pas le faire en
tout cas pas de façon classique lui son
but c'est de rester inaccessible
inatteignable par ces autres candidats
oui c'est ça parce que il considère que
pour faire court lui est en train de
sauver le monde pendant que les autres
font des meetings et qu' il ne boxe pas
dans la même catégorie
du coup avec cette crise ukrainienne cas
qu'on peut s'attendre sur cette campagne
électorale on sent que vif il faut quand
même se rappeler que c'est dans un peu
plus d'un mois on est quand même très
proches et on sent que cette crise peut
complètement éclipsé ça et c'est cette
guerre en ukraine peut complètement
éclipsé finalement cette campagne
présidentielle oui alors je pense que la
situation est très ouverte parce que
nous ne mesurons pas encore les
conséquences de ce de cette guerre pour
l'instant il n'y a pas de volet
militaire concernant la france puisque
nous sommes membres de l'alliance
atlantique aucun pays de l'otan a été
attaqué et donc même si nous avons porté
des forces dans l'est de l'europe il n'y
a pas d'action directe de l'autre ou le
deuxième volet diplomatique de ce côté
là emmanuel macron est extrêmement actif
il a encore une longue moi et me vladmir
poutine aujourd'hui au téléphone et ça
de ça les français lui savent gré et
puis il ya les autres conséquences et
conséquences économiques donc si d'ici
quelques jours le prix du blé augmente
fortement si le prix des carburants
augmentent fortement alors on aura
besoin d'une réponse concrète et là les
autres candidats pourront interpeller
emmanuel macron là dessus en disant que
faites vous
face à cette hausse subite des matières
premières et puis l'autre sujet c'est
celui des réfugiés et là pour le coup ça
n'est pas un problème entre guillemets
pour lui et pardon d'utiliser ce mot
parce que il y as et c'est heureux un
consensus dans l'opinion française et
d'eric zemmour est le seul à avoir dit
que ne souhaitait pas avoir de réfugiés
ukrainien en france et je pense que son
électorat aura du mal à le comprendre
donc de sur ce sujet là aussi emmanuel
macron pourra continuer à être entre
guillemets surplombant une question de
kriss kross qui rappelle quel est son
programme sur les retraites moi je ne
vote pas pour l'inconnu sans avoir le
programme c'est ce qu'on disait dans
dans sa lettre c'est encore assez flou
oui c'est encore assez flou alors il lui
reste
un mois pour pour détailler ces
propositions et je pense qu'elles vont
venir on sent bien que pour l'instant il
dit à travers cette lettre fait ma
confiance nous allons continuer comme si
il n'avait pas besoin de proposer tout
de suite des réformes concrètes pour
réussir à
avoir l'engagement des français donc je
comprends ce que nous dit notre ami kris
kross qui a hâte d'avoir le programme il
va venir mais encore une fois
emmanuel macron ne va pas changer de cap
donc il a été déjà dit que la réforme
des retraites serait à nouveau remise
sur le chantier après l'élection est ce
qu'il va être plus précis je suis pas
certain à mon avis pas forcément son
intérêt ce qui doit expliquer qu' il va
fusionner les différents régimes ou ou
est-ce qu'il va prendre des mesures
paramétrique c'est peut-être pas
forcément le coeur du neuf
présidentielle il semble sûr de lui et
du coup montrer à son électorat regardez
je lui ai fait savoir 50 réalisé moi
pendant cinq ans est ce que c'est une
stratégie qui peut marcher oui je le
pense alors d'abord pas moi qu'ils
pensent sont les français si on en croit
les les instituts de sondage les
intentions de vote et les cotes de
popularité le sel du duduk y paraît dans
le figaro magazine ce week-end ne montre
bien que il est il est à un niveau qui
est quasiment inédit pour un président
sortant candidat à sa réélection
qu'est ce qu'il ya comme com
marqueurs de ceux de ce bilan il ya la
crise sanitaire ou heureux hasard on
nous annonce que tout va mieux ça c'est
pas emmanuel macron qu'il a fait mais on
supprime le pass annie terre dans
quelques jours le kazakh signal qui a
annoncé le même jour le parce que
l'annoncent c'est curieux oui c'était
bien c'était tout ça est évidemment
organisée alors on peut dire que
emmanuel macron aurait pu lever plus
vite se passe vaccinale comme l'ont fait
d'autres pays comme le comme le royaume
uni mais les français je pense sont
plutôt satisfaits de la façon dont il a
géré la crise sanitaire donc en gros il
dit vous nous avez protégé du coc vide
vous faites de votre mieux pour vous
nous protéger de l'avenir poutine est
donc effectivement ce ce bilan il
apparaît comme plutôt positif parce que
les éléments objectivement mauvais que
sont la sécurité
c'est la sécurité du quotidien est en
fait celle ci est un peu passée au
second plan sans doute de la
préoccupation des français par rapport à
la sécurité immédiate qui est de savoir
est-ce qu'on va avoir une guerre en
europe et puis le deuxième point négatif
c'est l'endettement mais ça comme de
toute façon les français sont shootés à
la dépense publique depuis des dizaines
d'années il ne se rend même plus compte
ce n'est qu'après vous pas justement des
des sondages de l'avant et maquereau
dans les sondages on peut pas dire que
l'élection est déjà fait pour lui au
premier tour mais tout de même il y a
quand même une sacrée avance qu'il a
pour l'instant oui il y a une avance
très forte et surtout
il y a une forme de 2,2 d'imprécisions
dans les candidats qui le suivent c'est
à dire que
marine le pen semble être être devant
les autres mais elle est très loin de
lui comme si en fait le match n'était
pas vraiment cristallisé encore et
on sent bien que les autres candidats
ont du mal à trouver une réponse parce
que sur la gestion de la crise du crédit
n objectivement personne ne ferait
différemment de lui et lui qu'est ce
qu'il a comme avant sur les autres
candidats c'est qu'il a l'expérience et
que ça fait ça fait cinq ans les
présidents de la république vladimir
poutine il le connaît avec ses qualités
ses défauts et donc donc on pense qu'il
est les français pensent en outre qu'il
est plus à même d'agir donc si c'est en
ça que cette campagne est incroyable
parce que en fait
elle ne se cristallise pas ça fait des
mois qu'on dit ça on disait ça
cristallise pas pascal co vide
maintenant le coc vide apparemment est
derrière nous on touche du bois ensuite
ça se cristallise pas parce qu'il n'est
pas candidat maintenant il l'est mais ça
se cristallisera toujours pas parce que
encore une fois la crise j'ai créé une
hyène écrase tout effectivement sûr que
sur quoi peut-il faire que faire
campagne faire ouf au final pendant
pendant un peu plus d'un mois sur quoi
va t-il insisté le plus alors je pense
qu'il ya plusieurs points le premier
point c'est la protection mais ça à la
limite il n'a pas besoin de trop en
parler puisque c'est son action
diplomatique qui en est l'illustration
comme on l'a été sa façon de gérer la
crise sanitaire ensuite je pense qu'il y
à la modernisation ça c'est vraiment un
point sur lequel emmanuel macron n'a pas
varié vous savez qu'il ya un plan majeur
de relance d'investissement de
réindustrialisation qui qui va être
concrètement lancer dans les semaines
qui viennent puisque l'argent notamment
celui de bruxelles est débloqué petit à
petit donc il va dire je suis l'homme
qui modernise la france et ça va
vraiment être sasson son cap et puis
peut-être qu'il va y avoir cette
modernisation non seulement économique
mais aussi
dans l'école jeu on en parlait au début
mais c'est important de voir que c'est
l'un des rares sujets sur lequel il fait
les propositions presque concrètes en
disant plus d'autonomie pour pour les
airs viseur et et dans la dans la
gestion des carrières donc apparemment
il va se focaliser là dessus après il
peut y avoir des surprises emmanuel
macron n'aime rien tant que le que le
mouvement donc je pense que ce qu'on
voit là c'est une une sorte de feuille
de route esquissé mais c'est pas un
programme finalisé en parlant de
surprises d'alors sans faire de la delà
de la fiction mais est-ce qu'on peut
s'imaginer que emmanuel macron c'est
faux et dans les sondages dans les dans
le prochain mois c'est le propre de
l'avenir c'est qu'il est difficile à
prévoir mais pour l'instant on ne voit
pas cette situation je dirais que
l'intuition de 2017 qui a construit la
victoire d'emmanuel macron reste valable
c'est à dire de dire qu' il y a un
nombre important de français qui ne se
reconnaît plus dans une opposition
devenue artificielle entre une droite
réformiste et une gauche sociale
démocrate et qu' il ya la place pour
quelqu'un qui fasse la synthèse de ces
deux camps alors certains ont dit oui
mais ça a marché en 2017 parce que le
candidat socialiste était nul benoît
hamon parce que françois fillon avait
des casseroles mais qu'est ce qu'on voit
là ça n'est plus le cas il ya quand même
la maire de paris il ya
les répéter ce qu'ils sont des candidats
solides et qui ont du mal à accrocher
pourquoi parce que les français qui sont
dans ces deux camps là pour un certain
nombre d'entre eux disent pourquoi pas
continuer avec macron et ça ça montre
que 7,7 ce logiciel idéologique il reste
pertinent alors effectivement s'il fait
une erreur majeure il peut et de chuter
dans les sondages mais vous voyez ce les
fondamentaux restent les mêmes qu'en
2017 et on voit mal pourquoi ça
fonctionnerait moins bien merci beaucoup
guillaume roquette d'avoir été avec nous
ce soir pour décrypter cette cette
lettre d' emmanuel macron est-ce qu'on
peut peut-être pour ceux qui sont
arrivés un peu plus tard dans live
résumé ce qu'il faut retenir de cette
lettre alors oui ce qu'on peut dire
c'est que c'est une lettre que manuel
macron envoie aux français pour leur
dire qu'il est à nouveau candidat il
commence par dire que il est fier de son
bilan il n'a pas beaucoup d'auto
critique dans cette lettre mais il
affirme aussi qu'il faut continuer à
réformer le pays d'abord sur l'économie
avec en particulier la baisse des impôts
sur les entreprises pour avoir une
économie qui soient plus productives
il faut aussi que la france travaille de
plus annonce t-il il ya aussi quelques
propositions sur l'école mais on est
dans des vrais mans dans des généralités
donc encore une fois ce que demande
emmanuel macron aux français c'est
patent de valider un programme détaillé
que de lui faire confiance pour
continuer 50 plus sans qu'il y ait de
bouleversements dans le cap suivi merci
beaucoup guillaume merci à vous tous
d'avoir suivi ce direct et bien sûr vous
pouvez retrouver l'intégralité de cette
lettre sur le site du figaro indirect
est actuellement ouvert aussi sur le
site du figaro et bien sûr voilà
retrouver toutes les informations sur
votre site et moi je vous dis à bientôt
pour de nouveaux lives sur fear alive